ccsd starts another school year of class
on monday for one on the east side
though on campus it will be the first
new year mary jane belliesa has more on
where a new school is now open
acceleration academies isn't just a new
school but it's also providing a
non-traditional way for students to earn
their high school diploma
[Music]
this is the third clark county
acceleration academics campus to open
just in time for the
2022-2023 school year students
sidetracked with their education now get
another opportunity to earn their high
school diploma i think this is good
because i just need to be able to kind
of see the key alizea jones is an honor
roll student trying to balance school
and care for her younger siblings at
home now she's learning on her own pace
being given the independence that
acceleration gives you when you attend
it allows for you to feel better about
the work you're completing and you're
really going to take away a lot more
because it's up to you clark county
acceleration academics director wendy
thompson says the program is all about
individualized learning so every single
student in our school has a personal
advocate that reaches out to them
multiple times every week to help with
their social emotional needs to help
knock down some of their non-academic
barriers to success jones says the
flexibility and self-paced learning
options has helped her stay on track to
graduate this december i do want to take
some basic college courses out here
while i can just like my math biology
things like that but i definitely do
want to attend college i'm just trying
to figure out which one
like all public school programs this one
is free and open to students up to 21
years of age the other two campuses are
located on craig and clayton as well as
bonanza and lamb reporting from boulder
highway in tropicana mary jane belliesa
live local now